the cast and crew at NCIS are like
family so when some of the old-school
fan favorites decided to get together
for an online reunion of course we had
to be there and boy was it a wild one
let me turn my camera back on how do i
turn the camera back on
I bet Polly can't even find her zoom can
you believe that this is happening
I do people I see right now it's crazy I
mean the band is back together y'all
right now it's been 15 years since this
NCIS groups been together
Michael Pauly and Sasha have all moved
on to their own shows but Brian and
rocky will be back for season 18 of TV's
number-one drama we've witnessed the
chemistry between this cast since our
first visit on the set in 2003 I wanna
kiss every one of you and not a creepy
way I wasn't gonna miss this I got stuck
in traffic and I was supposed to be at a
location so I pulled off now there's a
there's a really nice police officer
waiting for me to get off this fall and
then all my cheat sheets which I stick
on other actors you were the like you're
the court jester man here we go here we
go Polly put the reunion together for a
good cause to help raise money for
Project Angel Food which provides food
to people impacted by serious illness
every single time I've reached out you
guys you guys say yes we're all here
because of her I'm hoping that people
see that and they say wow that's really
worthy
[Music]